cada 14 de noviembre se celebra el Día
Mundial contra la diabetes y Ese es
nuestro tema del día de hoy en salud con
Marina sardina Marina Buenos días y
cuéntenos por favor usted más sobre esta
enfermedad Buenos días Ángel Así es una
fecha importante porque ya en el mundo
más de 500 millones de personas padecen
esta enfermedad padecen de diabetes y se
prevé que el número además siga
aumentando en los próximos años hasta
780 millones de personas para el 2045
para entender Más de esta enfermedad
tenemos con nosotras al doctor Carlos
Eduardo Pérez Bienvenido a Franz 24
doctor Buenos días Quería preguntarte
existen dos tipos de diabetes cuéntanos
un poco Cuáles son estos tipos y cómo se
manifiestan en nuestra salud
sí Marina hay dos tipos de diabetes la
llamada diabetes tipo 1 que es la
diabetes que se llama juvenil porque
aparece en las primeras edades en las
primeras décadas y la diabetes tipo 2
que es una diabetes que se es de la edad
adulta y que se relaciona por ejemplo
como fenómenos como la obesidad este
tipo de diabetes hay otros tipos de
diabetes que son una mezcla de las dos
pero estas son las más importantes y las
que hoy se conmemora la lucha contra
ellas también doctor decíamos que ya 500
millones de personas padecen esta
enfermedad sin embargo cuatro de cada
cinco personas con con diabetes están en
países de ingresos bajos o medios a qué
se debe esto y Cómo afecta también es el
contexto socioeconómico en la salud de
estas personas que padecen diabetes en
la prevención y en el tratamiento
la diabetes es el exceso de azúcar por
la incapacidad de la insulina para
poderla procesar y está relacionado
directamente con los hábitos
nutricionales cuando hay exceso de
carbohidratos no es que los
carbohidratos todos sean daños sino el
exceso de estos carbohidratos y no hay
la forma de metabolizar estos
carbohidratos y ese exceso de azúcar que
se llama diabetes puede producir daños
en los órganos en los vasos sanguíneos
en los ojos en el cerebro del corazón en
muchos órganos eso se ha visto
relacionado con la pobreza por ejemplo
en dietas ricas de proteína o de fibras
y mucho más que está supeditada los
carbohidratos por razones de
hidratización económica los
carbohidratos son más económicos también
doctor en Estados Unidos se publicó un
estudio que señalaba también que las
personas hispanas latinas afroamericanas
o hacia asiático americanas tienen un
17% más de probabilidades de parecer
diabetes de tipo 2 que se está haciendo
desde los sistemas de salud público o
que se está haciendo para que estas
personas también reciban estos
departamentos y por qué les afecta más a
ellos
Sí todo esto que tiene que ver con los
Ultra procesados con las bebidas
azucaradas algunos gobiernos han tomado
la gestión de hacer gravamen sobre estos
consumos para disminuir el consumo y
también las políticas en los Colegios
acerca de la nutrición de los hábitos
saludables del ejercicio de evitar el
consumo exceso de estos alimentos
ultraprocesados de las bebidas con
exceso de azúcar hacen parte de lo que
tenemos que hacer para poder llegar a
una educación nutricional que impacta
realmente la prevención de la diabetes
hoy lo que vemos Es que la obesidad es
una consecuencia y causa de la diabetes
y vemos como los países más pobres y las
poblaciones más marginadas la gente no
está muriendo desnutrición sino de
obesidad de mal nutrición
doctor Buen día para ustedes le saluda
Ángela Gómez y los niveles altos de
insulina pueden llevar por ejemplo a un
déficit en la función cerebral también
afectan nuestro estado de ánimo nuestro
comportamiento nuestra cognición entre
otras cosas esa insensibilidad a la
insulina en el cerebro se puede
relacionar con la diabetes Cuáles son
los síntomas de la resistencia a la
insulina cerebral en nuestra salud
mental
Hola Ángela más que el déficit de
insulina es el exceso de azúcar
recordemos que cuando no hay insulina el
azúcar incrementa y el azúcar afecta los
vasos sanguíneos hace depósitos sobre
los vasos sanguíneos e impide la
circulación normal la circulación
cerebral es una circulación crítica
porque las arterias celulares son tan
delgadas como un cabello y si se
obstruyen pueden producir alteraciones
en las funciones cognitivas motoras de
el cerebro ese exceso de azul de azúcar
que lleva el daño de la microvasculatura
es lo que afecta a la Salud Mental las
déficits cognitivas el cerebro por eso
llevar una vida saludable hacer
ejercicio y tener unos hábitos de
alimentación saludables prevendrían esta
lamentable situación doctor y también la
diabetes causa Pues también graves
impactos en nuestra salud a largo plazo
y cuéntanos un poco lo que ya venías
mencionando no Cuáles son estas
recomendaciones desde la sanidad para
poder prevenirlo y también Qué efectos
tienen en nuestra salud este tipo de
enfermedad pero también si hay alguna
relación con los genes no con la
herencia
sí existe algo de predisposición
genética y se suma también a factores
ambientales como el exceso de azúcar una
confección personal yo soy diabética y
el cambio que tuvo que hacer en mis
hábitos nutricionales Pues me ha llevado
a que tenga una vida saludable en estos
años eso qué quiere decir que las
personas y padecen diabetes no es una
enfermedad mortal es una enfermedad
Crónica controlable deben asistir al
médico y cumplir cumplir con la
recomendaciones nutricionales y
farmacéuticas que se les administran y
por otro lado a nuestros niños a
nuestros jóvenes a que aprendamos los
hábitos saludables de alimentación los
alimentos ultraprocesados las bebidas
con exceso de azúcar conducen a daños en
la salud y a los gobiernos para que
implementen estrategias para disminuir
el consumo de estos elementos y se
reemplace por alimentos más naturales
orgánicos y que permitan un control
glicémico en toda nuestra población
pues viene Gracias a usted doctor
Gracias Marina por enviarnos sobre este
tema y pues a enfocarnos más en la
prevención totalmente gracias Ángela
vamos ahora con el invitado del día